hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to dimension 2 now
still playing on the sequence because
I'm really enjoying the game and I can't
stop playing and I got a key to 302 now
what that means I do not know I don't
even know what I need these antidote
bottles for and I've got like two bars I
might just notice I have like two bars
on my health bar like ones my regular
health which I need to fill up by the
way and the other ones just like I don't
know what it is so oh no I'm just
scavenging for ammo right now I guess I
got a lot of revolver bullet they could
start using that again
no thank you oh god I don't know why
these things are getting freakier over
time like they shouldn't it should be
the exact level of breeki that they are
but nope
very disturbing oh ok
top it goddamnit yeah boy you got damn
chair gasps damn douche bag Mother
Hubbard a little bit okay you're still
weird but not as weird as before okay
I'm fine who am Oh God oh yes okay gosh
I got him alright so I got three Oh -
what's in this door
you dead are you dead
are you dead you guys get such hamd in
the head
you dead hey this day dead
you better take that you mother
I better this debate up you staged a
do-over okay William I want to see you
but they are making it so difficult
our safe house is west of here remember
I may have a surprise for you
meet me there I changed our code it is
now one-to-one you must hurry
Elizabeth X oh no xox this time I'm not
good okay all right the stain that was
an opportunity to get me didn't get me
very weird
one two one I could have guessed that
code very easily like if I went through
just a sequence of numbers trying to get
the code that would have been like fifth
on my list one through nine I guess not
close to fifth but you know what I mean
you know what I mean okay I'm gonna go
back and get this right now because I
can and then hit up the other stuff
later cuz if they're wait how yeah yeah
cuz if this is a long hallway that leads
that looks like at least to the end I
don't know but either way I can make my
way back and then I can actually hit the
save point because I am very worried
that you know the game could crash there
at any moment and I could lose
everything that I have progressed Oh No
that ghosty goo still around here I
don't see him where the hell did he go
alright okay if you say so
okay gonna hit the save point first then
move on to other things yeah okay all
right got it got it got it got together
okay moving on all right okay let me hit
this up wanna hear another story about
childhood markiplier oh no no that way
there we go got it
yeah when I was uh again growing up
through high school I was a very awkward
kids but like guys yeah shut up you I
got shotgun with your name on it but
either way like when I was in high
school like I said I was in band alot so
I made a lot of band friends and I had
this core group of like three guy or
four guys that we were four in total
including me and we went on the trip
flot and we went on to round two things
in and had a lot of fun together and one
things that I did that a lot of you guys
will probably like was you know my open
the door get on the floor everybody do
the dinosaurs really everybody walk the
dinosaur but are they I used to do this
thing like out in total public
especially when we were down in
Disneyland for like this big marching
band thing or whatever and I would
literally literally when I came out of
this ride ad when came out of this ride
that had like the barely minimal thing
to do with dinosaurs I literally had
this thing where outgoing walk like a
dinosaur through the park like a very
strange kid grown up and like it would
make my friends laugh like nobody's
business probably just cuz he were
embarrassed to be around me but I just
did it cuz it made him laugh and that's
how I first kind of discovered that I
like making people laugh it's kind of
one of my favorite things to do now me I
don't want to be like a stand-up
comedian I don't think I'd be any sort
of funny in that regard but hey if I
could make you guys laugh that's a thing
so I want you all dev of this project
like when you go meet your friends today
like I don't even care if they like
markiplier just like anything that gets
you angry you like
making me angry charge out a mica
dinosaur just do it do it please do it
for me done I'm begging you do this for
me just do the book come on come on
okay so anyway oh no oh my look your key
skeleton key oh how foreboding and
ominous a skeleton key just for you and
me to go and see our house by the sea
and then you'll get a face full of me if
you know what I mean
that came out much dirtier than I want
to do they got here first they took a
man I'm going to the church take the key
meet me there they will come this will
end that's not good that's not good at
all so wait a minute this criminally
insane place was directly next door to
this town where you lived in is that
what I'm trying to get here that would
make sense if like you work there or
something but I don't think you did or
maybe you did I don't know I still don't
get much of the story of this game other
than that this guy is probably being
framed by the same dime probably not
because he seems kind of crazy died the
way I know I'm like totally off topic
with like my stories of might out there
tonight I apologize sincerely for that
I'm not sorry at all
but either way yeah I'll focus on the
game don't worry I've got the game still
focused in on me so anyway let me
actually save real quick and then I'll
bugger off to the other end and
hopefully I can get to the end of the
level here I don't know if that'll end
the chapter but I can definitely get to
the end of the level and maybe there'll
be another boss who knows maybe maybe
bring it on I got a revolver
oh I ain't backtracking in games Oh God
Jesus okay alright nevermind okay moving
on moving on moving on all right okay
moving on I hate the ghosty ku he's like
the creepiest thing ever and that's not
even the same as the other the other
ghosty groove is creepier than that one
it just surprised me cuz they're utterly
silent maybe there is the ghostly wail
that they do
oh no okay so I went in there that was
the hotel great lake in rather so down
Oh down okay
down here there should be the thing and
then the thing okay I don't know where
the skeleton key go but I'm hoping stop
laughing at me
oh god what is that wow that is new I
thought that laugh was just a little bit
different oh god shut up okay
Oh God okay I'm not sure that thing was
laughing at me it was like it started
out laughing and then it's a kind of
desperate screams oh very weird
oh I don't like the things that this
thing otherwise known as a game that I'm
playing it's just disturbing a lot like
horrific Elise Carrie but they're just
like oh don't I don't want I want
nothing to do with that oh this looks
good
so does Mikey go to here
go stop find a man to bring her to me
what I have a skeleton key that looks
weird okay all right here we go
Oh skeleton door of course oh yeah now I
need to go get Amanda who I'm assuming
is my daughter oh haha oh good this
looks good
I like this yeah wait her ghastly
skeletal form and translucent skin
cannot lure the young male victim male
victims that she desires reports claimed
that which can transform into her former
beauty to attract her prey it is their
hearts that she truly desires
you mean like la oh you don't mean like
you mean like a little bit that kind of
thing you know you know you know you
know like Indiana Jones you know you
don't know
I see you there Oh what are you right
what are you
it's a shovel oh I know what I need to
do how do I use it
laughs [ __ ] hell god damn don't
startle me like that I got my volume way
up don't do that to me
come on die into his I don't know if
they do have a like a weak point maybe
they do oh they got a heart in there oh
I didn't see that before okay so maybe
if I hit him in their heart that's why
someone down really quickly and some did
not
ah come on if really the one at the end
how cliche let me try to hit their heart
no didn't do anything I was like right
on target they do maybe it does I don't
know I'll aim for their hearts it seems
like a logical weak point oh come on
you're below nning me where the hell
with the other Oh is there another level
down come on heart our Chuck our Chuck
are shy
I think it is a weakness I believe
anyway okay more graves I bet you know
just the logic of this game it's not at
the bottom it's not in the Middle East
at the very bottom like right here okay
wasn't expecting that the child's doll
Oh
oh good no no now stop jumping you jumpy
little bastard no stop okay you're dead
or shot or shot so did I get the thing
was that Amanda that I got come on hard
shot there we go I don't know maybe that
just killed him oh excuse me pardon I
don't have any more bullets to uh doc
gun mode okay uh the only reason I knew
it was down there is because this game
has been very obvious and not really
subtle with its puzzles are clues so I
was like logically speaking they'd
probably I did at the bottom because
that would be the most obvious place to
hide it oh my mirror is gone oh come on
I'm actually running low on bullets
period I need more I probably need to
save it I should probably use my sledge
there ready to get stretched
oh not you bastards fine you want some
oh don't laugh at me I'm so so slow
come on stop moving around whoa whoa
whoa whoa I didn't even notice my health
was like almost completely gone oh I'm
being poisoned or am i I don't know
screw it oh come on forgetting that only
has two bullets there we go
come on okay you're going down
mano a knife oh there we go ah my health
man is that what the poison is what is
that I don't know what that is so
confused
so confused I have to fight another damn
block with my knife I'm gonna be very
upset I think it's actually quicker to
kill things with my knife than my
sledgehammer wait a minute another
flashback to another gaming flashback
okay guess well guess what I think this
looks like before I guessed it quake one
right here quake one
did you guess quake one yeah all right
take your prize like what the hell are
you talking about mark oh you die mister
markiplier that doesn't look anything
like that yeah I know whatever Stan god
I was just enjoying it whatever come on
if you thought a quake one right in the
comments below like right here this
right here yeah
ooh do I get another boss I don't have
enough man what are those butts are
those butts
those are butts Oh what's with the roll
but why does they're chained up butts oh
oh it's with the but that's not Oh was
our butts those torsos ever mind oh no
no no what the hell did I get a button
oh come on at the end of it I think I
might've accidentally clicked my mouse
there whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa you
they Julie hey what's going on
No Arden can't see anything
what is that Oh tree okay oh oh oh
all right then I'm gonna oh there you
are I've gotta get you oh no pretty lady
oh oh that is disturbing okay how do I
have any bullets I think I got revolver
bullets yeah I'm gonna get to it
ah I see yeah where'd you go ah gotcha
Bob oh I thought I could get her before
she got me hello that does not do much
damage to her oh forget my split Nam I
think I need to use the knife
I think the knife's the only thing
that's actually damaging her god damn it
she's just gonna do that stupid attack
got her yeah there we go
I'm almost rapier come back here come
here
what what are you doing what are you
doing my doing but that wasn't what oh
hey
ah come on pretty good yeah hello
no no no no no no no under that none of
that
hey yeah oh come on I'm right there
there you are
whoa whoa whoa okay oh come on
trying to get her I really am guys but
it's not that easy apparently come on
not being a pain in the butt
come here nope nope no no no no Gus
place yeah see you're not my wife I
didn't kill my wife
well I'm gonna kill you Wow I'll slice
you up that's right that's right come on
come at me ah come on come on yeah yeah
come for oh you don't actually hurt me
all that much so I mean not that big a
deal
where'd you go where'd you go ah come on
oh come on fellas dad Oh
come on come on
ah come on she's not hurting me very
much but I'm just gonna take her like
full force ah get you [ __ ] come on
bring it on you yeah come on you come on
come here
where'd you go oh no ow whoa I got
tossed around you what oh my god Jesus
lady you want to die you can come right
oh no no no don't fool me not fooling me
Oh bullying me he was not bullying me
that was the whole thing she was not
fine Jesus she was not fooling me that
was the point oh it's gonna stab her
okay come on come at me lady the hell
you are cute that's great
what oh what's that oh yeah don't hurt
me but it's true [ __ ] hurt you nowhere
yet well yeah we're yeah come on what
you go yeah why would I even need the
first aid kit I don't if the pills
seemed to do the job Oh nope yeah go
happen
you walk around all black a days ago
nope ain't gonna happen
come come Brina yeah oh come on no not
the stupid green gooey wall of death
thing yeah oh come on
so I'm doing this emptily oh come on dad
when in reality I really did
come on bring it on
oh come on stop doing the green thingy
just come at me just come at me
ah yes Oh she keep doing the oh I had
you ah come on you weren't even close to
me that time your aim is the awful lady
may because you're blind or whatever
which you are I don't care how hot you
think you are
nope nope you get you get blown it now
no basket ah well now come at me mm nope
uh-uh that's a lie but a BAM no I'm
gonna show you I'm not going over there
I wanna shoot you no I can't
oh no and you can't I can't beer Kimber
the shooting of you what do I get
oh no got you ah you tried to kill me
that time but it didn't work come back
to your stupid yeah come on I hit her
come on there we go landed I hit come on
yeah it's my trihard face by the way if
you can tell yeah yeah I'm gonna get you
right you do your thing you do your
thing come on yeah almost gotcha almost
got you lady
Oh
ah did you buy your balls nope nope huh
what's that you want some bullets oh no
no no bamm-bamm yeah nope lies no lies
no lies oh so she was pretending to be
my wife
okay so maybe I didn't actually live
here I don't know what oh okay I got the
knife that's how I won that over I think
okay yes maybe so I think oh it's a
letter we thought moving here would keep
us safe from the wickedness of modern
life but the evil has come regardless it
is clear now that there is no safe
harbor on earth we will meet God in
heaven and take arms that is side people
will think us crazy they do not know the
truth about the world after this we are
still and will always be heavens hope
number one number one baby
all right to whom it may concern I
hereby bequeath all my remaining earthly
possessions to whoever find this letter
they are located in the chest at the
foot of my bed
I hope they serve you well since I won't
be needing them where I'm going number
oh well all right then so you're dead
that's awesome
good god I guess this was some sort of
suicide pact I'm so sorry I think I've
made a terrible mistake but there's no
going back now I help you and God
forgive me I hope I love you and dad too
please tell him it wasn't his fault I
moved out your baby girl surely that's
sad so this was some sort of suicide
cult they were very concerned about the
world beyond or something too late for
the prison now you must go back to the
prisoners Oh too late for escape now you
must go back to the prison and stop him
this will help you three five to six
five
three five two six five yeah okay all
right
got it got it all right wasn't anything
else pizzelles laughing in here because
I gotta cut it soon I need to get to a
save point this part is gone going on a
little too long but I'm flexible I'm
gonna go where was it where was this
date point I don't even remember now oh
just over here okay there's no all right
it'll be right over here okay go all
right let me get it yeah yeah alright
yeah ok so anyway this is the last one
I'm gonna record in this set so after
this it'll be I'll be able to read
comments and see what you guys think of
the game I am really liking this game
it's it's a lot of fun in and I'm still
amazed because for a DES port it's not
bad I mean I can forgive some of the
calm the combat mechanics of it yeah I
can forgive some of the combat mechanics
of it I mean it's not too horrible but I
really do like the the atmosphere and
especially this sound and some of the
monsters just plain old disturbing some
of the settings are playing with
disturbing so I actually really liked it
so if you guys liked it and you want to
see more make sure I know in the
comments below let me know what you
think about if you want me to stop then
say that but I mean I'll take it all
into consideration but I don't think I'm
gonna stop I think I want to keep
playing this so anyway thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos that I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]
[Applause]